[音楽]
こんにちは私はリーガンジャパンで働いている研究科学者です
私はまた、日本で
最大かつ最高の小児病院の1つで働い
ていた小児科医の子供医師でもあります。
全国の他の病院の子供たち、
そして私たちがそのような相談をするとき、私たちは
常に
それらの患者を私たちの病院
に運ぶ方法を考えています。
通常の状態で、または日常
生活を送っているとき、たとえば、歩いているとき、
食べているとき、考えているとき、または眠っているときでさえ、
ある程度のエネルギーを使用し
、健康な状態では、
エネルギー供給とエネルギー需要の
バランスが取れていますが、 病気の
エネルギー供給は縮小し、したがってこの
バランスが損なわれ、
重篤な状態は
現代医学が何らかの形でこのエネルギーを回復しようとする深刻なケースの1つ
です プライと私たちは薬や
いくつかのデバイスを使用します、または時々私たちはこのエネルギー供給を回復するために人的資源を使用します
、そしてそれが
重病の患者が彼らの体にたくさんのチューブまたは
たくさんのデバイスを取り付けている理由です
そして私たちがこれらを輸送しようとしているとき
患者は通常、
救急車または医療用ヘリコプター
を使用します。これらの車両のいずれかに乗ったことがある場合
は、患者から得られる最も有益な兆候の1つは、患者が発する音であるということを知っておく必要があります。
それは心臓の鼓動
音または患者の呼吸音であ
り、それらの車両ではそれ
らの音を聞くことは非常に困難であり
、それは私たちが患
者を評価することを非常
に困難にし、またそれらを輸送することを非常に困難にします
呼吸器系の患者に問題がある場合、私たちは
しばしば
彼らを培養します。挿管とは、輸送時に
気道を保護するために気管内にチューブを挿入することを意味します。
最悪のシナリオでは、システムが非常にでこぼこしていて、
これらのチューブが移動し
、患者を簡単に殺す可能性があるため、
患者が病気であると判断した場合、輸送をあきらめなければならないことがあります。
つまり
、これらの患者
は 元の病院はまた
、適切な薬や治療を与えることができないことを意味し
、それは非常に悲しい
ことです。ある朝
、ICUでの長い夜のシフトの直後でし
た。私はとても疲れていて、とても眠くて
カップを飲みました。 コーヒーを飲んで職員
室に戻り、机の上に座って医学雑誌を見つけました。
その雑誌は
最新号でもあり
ませんでした。普段はしていない
ことをしました。疲れていたからだと
思います。 因果的にそのジャーナルを取り、
理由もなくジャーナルをめくり、
ある記事が私の目に飛び込んできました。その
記事は、霊長類が休止状態に入ることができると主張しました
。
キャサリン・ダスマン
この霊長類が
マダガスカル
で冬眠に入っているのを見つけたグループです彼らが完璧な熱帯地域で冬眠を見つけたことを知っているのはすでに驚くべきことです
が、私にとって
印象的だったのは、この言葉が由来
する冬眠に入ることができる霊長類を見つけたこと
です
ラテン語は冬を過ごすことを意味し、
日本語では冬眠と書きます。
動物が冬眠に入ると
、通常、代謝が
非常に低くなり、
体温が低下し
ます。つまり、エネルギー需要が失われ
、場合によっては深刻な場合があります。
彼らはエネルギー需要を
通常の1％まで失いまし
た。私たちが健康なときはエネルギー供給
とエネルギー需要のバランスが取れており、
病気になるとエネルギー供給が減少
し、現代医学が試みる健康な人々のエネルギー予算を思い出してください。 どういうわけか
このエネルギー供給を回復するが、これ
をバランスさせる別の方法があると思いませんか
エネルギー需要を安全に減らすことができれば、再びバランスを取ることができます。
これは、休止状態の
ときに休止状態の人が行っている
ことです。この記事を
突然見たとき、休止状態を誘発できるかどうかを考え始めました。
人間であり
、患者に休止状態を誘発することができれば
、それは私たちが輸送を指示する集中的なケアを必要としないことを意味し、それは私たちが
これらの患者を私たちの病院に輸送
することを可能にすることを意味
します 基礎研究分野に足を踏み入れて
休止療法を発見または開発し、
その日にドクターコースに応募し
てから10年以上経ちましたが
、今では
医療輸送だけ
が 人間の休止状態私
は網膜再生と呼ばれる研究室に所属しており
、メンバーのほとんどは
人間のiPS細胞から網膜組織を作っています。
それらの組織への休止は、
それらを保存できることを意味し、
組織を停止し、その後、
それらの組織の大量生産が可能に
なります。これは、再生医療のコストを劇的に削減することも意味します。
これは、ヒトiPS
由来の局所再生だけでなく、
古典的な
移植医療にも適用できます。ドナーで
ある脳から心臓を取り除くと、
それらの心臓を新しい
体に数時間入れるのに4時間しかかからないことをご存知でしたか？
これらの組織に誘導できれば、 制限
も延長され、医学は
人間の休止状態だけでなく、私たちを宇宙に連れて行く可能性があると思います
今、多くの
人々が月や火星に行く私たちから逃げようとしていることを知っ
ています 宇宙船では
資源を置く場所が限られているので
、この部屋の誰もが
私たちが代謝を減らすことができれば同意するだろうと私は信じています
乗組員の数
を増やしたり、ロケットの資源を効率的に使用したりするのに非常に役立つ、働くことができる乗組員のリズムです。
少なくとも火星に行くためには、
人間の冬眠は非常に
役立つと思います。
人間の冬眠は必須であり、
地球を愛する人や地球を離れたくない人の
ために、別の
アプリケーションを提供できます。人間の冬眠
は、冬眠中の老化プロセスを冬眠者が抑制すると信じている科学者のタイムマシンである
可能性があります。 あなたは100年の
冬眠状態にあります100年後あなたは冬眠に
入ったのと同じ年齢で目覚めます
そして他のすべてのものは100
歳でありそれは
未来に向かっているのですべてがうまくいけば
人間の冬眠は私たちを連れて行くと思います
将来的には、冬眠の研究を始めたとき、今はタイムマシンになる可能性があり
ます。どのような動物を研究するかを選択する必要
があり、次の
ような魅力的な冬眠動物がたくさんいます。
クマ、コウモリ、リス、ハムスターですが、私
はそれらを選びませんでした。代わりに、マウスとマウスを選び
ました。たとえば、冬眠者から多くの利点があります。
たとえば、
可用性が非常に高く、
遺伝子エンジニアが非常に簡単に持ち込むことができます。
これらの動物やマウスでは、
冬眠には入りませんが、冬眠
と呼ばれる状態になります。これは
冬眠の非常に短いバージョンであり、
3年前、私たちのグループは、マウスに
この毎日の休眠を誘発する非常に安定した方法を報告し、
そのシステムを使用しました。
毎日の
休眠が冬眠と何らかの機能を共有していることを発見
し、
共同研究者でスキューバ大学
の櫻井武と高橋トトと一緒に、これらの動物の脳を直接刺激し
て冬眠を作ろうとしている
ので、私たち
は もちろん人間を含む
非冬眠者に冬眠を誘発するために着実な一歩を踏み出しました
これまで私は
このファンタストがどのように
冬眠のic機能は
私たちに使用できます私は人間や人間社会に慣れていることを意味し
ますが、最近
、
冬眠中にエネルギーの1％しか使用しない冬眠者がいる
ことを述べた
ので、冬眠を研究する別の側面があることに気付きました。  99％の酸素や新陳代謝を使っています。
それはまた、新陳代謝の1％しか使っていなくても死ななかったことを意味します。その
1％には、
私
たちがまだ生きるために知らない本質的な機能があると思います。
冬眠は私たち
を医学を通して生き残らせ、冬眠
は私たちを宇宙や未来に連れて行くことができると思います
が、冬眠
は人生とは何かというこれまでに尋ねられた最も基本的な質問の1つに答えることができ
ます
[拍手]
あなた